nobody like wearing my shoes they like
wearing my shoes which is which is cool
but I'm like okay you know you feel a
little like I just they're still babies
but they do and they bet their good
balance or so I was thinking getting
them stilts like turn it into a crack
Eva Mendes's daughters are building
their makeup skills and well mommy
she's practice the actress and fashion
designer took to Instagram to show off
this look courtesy of her and Ryan
Gosling's daughters five-year-old
Esmerelda and four-year-old Amara the
girls made their mom's eyes pop with the
bright blue eyeshadow and they topped it
off with a touch of purple lipstick and
mismatched blush Ava hilariously
captioned the photo quote they won Salma
Hayek and Debi Mazar took to the
comments to praise the makeup artist
Selma comments it quote love this and
Debby wrote quote they did a great job
cool because they're so like they're so
free this isn't the first time ava has
received an extreme makeover from her
daughters while in quarantine she shared
an adorable pic of their work last week
captioning the photo quote I've lost any
control I once had last month
Ava shared a portrait one of her girls
had drawn of her she captioned the photo
quote this is me by my kid it's pretty
accurate no I haven't become a master
baker or a good cook during quarantine I
haven't seen a gym in two months I
hadn't written a novella I've just been
trying to be a fun mom and not lose my
marbles it's very important for me for
them to see me as just mom Ava opened
ups et earlier this year about how
having her girls has influenced her
career it's just like now that I have
children I'm kind of extreme there's
just so many things I won't do
like I won't do most of the movies I've
done and in the past yes you take them
into consideration chorus so a lot of
things are off that list and I don't
want to do anything too violent of
course I don't want to do anything too
sexual
so I basically like Disney I'm all yours
Disney that's all that's left
could you do a Disney movie like I'd
like to see where the princess Disney
Plus I'm aware of the villain kind of
type of girl so yes I'd like to do a
more the Ursula type you know yeah
[Music]